the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so today I'm going to talk about
mast taproot and graft route and these
are pretty cool new ideas in Bitcoin
they're not really production-ready
they're still sort of ideas but it's
kind of neat to look at the future
directions of how people are thinking
about improving these protocols so we're
going to talk about new types of scripts
mast taproot and graft route and all the
sort of interactions between these three
things I will define these of course
okay so so far we've talked about
scripts and you've got op codes you've
got a stack I think with the homework
people sort of got the idea of okay I
can do off return I can do op check sig
you know and the basic idea of how it
works so right now in Bitcoin it's
mostly pay to pub key hash so most of
the scripts that you'll see most of the
output scripts and then in an output
look like this right op dupe up flash
160 some pub key hash people verify up
check sake and then when you want to
execute this script you put a pub key
and a signature as your input it
duplicates the pub key hashes it pushes
this hash on to it checks that those two
things are equal and this also removes
those two things leaving only the
signature and then checks the signature
so if they're not equal if you try to
sign with a different pub key than the
one that is committed to in this bump
key it'll fail at this point and if you
put the right pump key but the wrong
signature it'll fail at this point right
so the well it'll fail the check sig
will fail put a zero on the stack and
then the stack will have a zero on it
and that'll fail verify means
immediately fail if these things are not
equal okay and then in seg what we sort
of a template in it so really this
entire script became op 0 pub key ash
which is confusing
if you don't know what that means wait
op 0 means just put a 0 on the stack and
then put a pub key hash on the stack and
and
one can spend this but the idea in
segments is yes software that is not
aware of segue will see this as
spendable by anyone without a signature
software that is aware of segue knows
that these two things are the same so
essentially if you see this turn it into
this right
take the pub key hash and fill in these
op codes and that's actually what the
code does for the script interpreter
it'll say oh it matches this template
it's op 0 and a 20-byte piece of data
turn it into this and then execute it so
in this way segue it saves 3 bytes right
because now you have one byte there
instead of one two three four you lose a
couple more bites elsewhere and sangwich
so it actually tends to lose it a couple
bites but whatever okay so this this
works this makes sense any questions
about beta punky hash works okay okay
and there's also pay to script hash this
is the other thing you'll see quite a
bit of in Bitcoin today I don't know
what the ratios are 80% paid a pumpkin
has 20% of beta script - something like
that
so minority but significant and for paid
a script ash it looks like this also
sort of template right up hash 160 a
script hash top equal that's it
this also seems like wait all I have to
do is provide a pre image of this and
then I'll be able to spend the coins but
the script interpreter knows no actually
what this means if you see this template
if you see this format verify that this
is equal and then execute whatever the
pre image was as a script so actually
the first time I started programming
Bitcoin stuff I did not know about paid
a script hash and I was just trying to
make my own transactions and I used this
I just said well I want to see that I
can you know get the script to execute
right I'll just take a random number
hash it put it into this thing and try
to spend it and it never worked and I
didn't know why and then a few days
later I read about pay to script and I
was like oh no wait it wasn't days later
I just put an OP I put an op no op op
one-sixty script pêche up equal and then
it worked and I was like okay I don't
know how Bitcoin works this doesn't make
any sense I put a no op and then it
starts working and then a few days later
I read about paid a script cash and it
was oh this actually has a special
meaning this is a template where if you
have - 60 a bunch of data and not equal
then it interprets the preimage as a
script does it have to be 20 bytes
probably yeah I don't know there's
actually a vulnerability here that the
how pay to script hash got introduced is
sort of an interesting debate there was
like op eval paid a script hash a bunch
of argument about it and this was in
2012 I think or 11 or 12 and it it was
sort of contentious and people argue
about it and and in retrospect this is
actually insecure because you're using
hop hash 160 which is 160 bytes hash
function it's basically sha 256 followed
by ripe MD 160 this is not big enough
right you have you're committing to a
script cache which is 20 bytes
however cool so normally you're like
yeah whatever 160 bits is plenty you can
have collision attacks where if you're
doing multi-sig with someone else they
may be able to calculate different pub
keys so that your pump key you know they
have a collision where two different 20
bite scripts hash to the same thing
there's sorry two different scripts hash
to the same 20 bytes this is possible
because that's only two to the 80 work
which is still a lot and used to be
considered like no one can do it to the
80 is like beyond any human endeavor but
Bitcoin does - to the 80 work every day
hour
I don't know something fairly reasonable
so so now it's like wait - of the 80 is
not enough we need you reach for the
same security as Bitcoin which is
generally a two to the 128 security
parameter we would need this to be 256
bits instead of 160 so when they
upgraded the segment paid a witness
script hash
this has to be 32 bytes to eliminate any
of those collisions of ulnar abilities
so yeah so that's what distinguishes it
so they look the same right
it's just op 0 piece of data obsolete
but they do completely different things
based on how long the state is okay so
that's pay descript hash any questions
about the basic construction good ok I
want to these free keys must sign in
order to spend the coins so I say up to
push three public keys onto the you know
three public keys up three up check
models you say so the idea is two of
these three must sign so you can put off
lon
this OP three you can put up three this
up three if you put up four three keys
and then up three it probably will never
be spendable and just never work I'm
pretty sure you have to put the
signatures in the correct order so when
you spend you say op zero sig a 6e and
then it's a see if you put sig see sig a
it fails right okay this is a fun little
part where you have to put in a zero
byte before the signature is when you
want to spend I'm not a hundred percent
sure how that got in it was the screw up
and we're just we just live with it
forever you don't put the OP 0 it
doesn't work and it's somewhat confusing
it wastes the byte which is not a huge
deal but it's just like what and they
didn't fix that in segue right yeah we
just stays in there who knows if it'll
ever get out
so saying it was an opportunity to fix
it but yes
hard work so you put this in and you
could say wait
that's stupid wait you need a zero in
front when you put the signors let's get
rid of that so so now the old software
says no I need a zero here and then if
you if you don't put the zero and you
just put the two signatures I fail this
script and then it could just be any
note any data and it was like any data
any data on the stack would get it would
get popped off right yeah and then the
two signatures so if you said let's
eliminate that requirement that would
actually be a hard fork because it would
be allowing scripts that were previously
invalid to now become valid and that's a
huge undertaking that has sort of only
happened once in Bitcoin and that wasn't
even planned and so it's just like
whatever leave it they did soft work it
then wait is it software or policy okay
so they didn't sophomore could say it
needs to be a zero so it could be
non-standard or it could be an actual
consensus rule that that has to be a
zero it used to be anything and now it's
it should be a zero put a zero and then
it'll work
but that that remains in segments as
well with multi-sig they could have
fixed it they didn't want to touch it it
was just like whatever let you know when
you see a when you see one of these turn
it into one of these and just do the
exact same thing you used to be doing
that's a lot simpler and easier okay so
kind of weird but this works right
people use this a lot especially
exchanges exchanges almost I very very
often use this kind of construction
because it helps people manage keys if
one key gets compromised you don't lose
all your money usually two of three
sometimes three or four three of three
two of to all sorts of constructions
where this is extremely useful and
actually I'll be talking about more
powerful signature aggregation and
multi-sig on Wednesday but for now this
is what we use and how can
we make this better so one interesting
thing pay to pub key which is not really
used anymore but used to be mused more
frequently like in the early days like
if you look at transactions in 2009-2010
this is predominant I think and like all
the mining outputs from a long time ago
looked like this and the script the
output script was just pump key objects
ache which is really simple and then the
idea is when you want to spend it you
just push a signature on to the stack
then you have signature pub key op check
sig that's it it's really simple and it
actually saves space right your pub key
is 33 bytes whereas your pub key hash
script the the pub key hash is 20 bytes
so yeah the pub key hash is 12 bytes
smaller plus the extra op codes makes it
10 bytes savings for the output script
right however when you spend with pay to
pump key hash you need to put the pump
key itself and the signature so you're
putting that you're putting the pub key
into the network either way eventually
so this is actually overall more space
efficient in that you're saving 23 bytes
over the life cycle of it right when you
the output is a little bit bigger but
the input is significantly smaller so
you end up saving why why do we always
use pub key hashes instead of pump keys
then does anyone there's a lot of
different opinions on it and there's no
you know it's a Bitcoin there's no like
answer people have different ideas of
why these are better any it is
yeah that's a that's a really probably
the predominant one and that's gonna be
a tricky one to try to convince people
is not the case because I'll get to that
but we people started arguing about like
funky Asha won when when someone posted
about grassroot everyone the discussion
devolved into a wait I don't want my pub
key on the network and and there's some
arguments why you'd want a pub key hash
and it's more secure but there's a lot
of arguments that it doesn't actually
provide any extra security so that's a
tricky one but that is one that is
probably a big one people like other
ideas why do use punky hashes instead of
pub keys themselves okay so sighs you
want the outputs to be small also I'm
pretty sure when Satoshi wrote all this
he did not know about compressed public
keys because that stuff was not in there
for a while so I think I think I
mentioned this before right did I
mention compressed versus uncompressed
web keys yeah probably
okay so review the idea is you've got
this whole curve kind of deal kind of
thing and your your public key is a
point on the curve you need an x and
y-coordinate to represent the point
however because it's symmetric you can
just say well I'll tell you the x
coordinate you know x equals seven I'm
not going to tell you the y coordinate
I'll just say y equals plus so Y you
know go up or go down that way I can do
32 bytes for this and one bit for that
had the cost of a little bit of extra
computation because then when I when I
see you know so I could say maybe Y is
actually five or something so if I say x
equals seven y equals five that's quick
but it takes more space if I say x
equals seven y equals plus I not have to
compute what Y is when I see this which
is pretty quick
what takes some time but it's good
trade-off anyway I don't think Satoshi
knew about this idea
or it may be thought of it never put it
in so the public keys were actually 65
flights you want to keep the outputs
small because they're in the UT Exocet
they're in the database and you need to
be alone through this and read it
randomly like you don't know when it's
gonna get spent so you don't know what
transaction is going to query this so
this has to go in like an actual
database key value store kind of thing
the signatures are don't have to be in
any database they're just in these old
blocks and you read from them linearly
you basically read for the whole block
at a time and high latency is fine
there's never any timing critical reads
for this so basically you can just you
could store the blocks as just files on
your hard drive you know block block 1
dot dat or whatever block 2 dot that and
have 500,000 files because you basically
always read them a block at a time
and you and you only have to read them
when peep other people are doing IBD
initial block download and you're
serving them to them so you can prune
these if you run a Bitcoin core with
pruning anyway so that the main set idea
is ok even if it overall increases the
size of transactions it does reduce the
size of the outputs which is the thing
we really want to minimize for keeping
the speed up ok questions about that
cool ok so similarly same thing with
beta punky hash and you know versus pay
to punky instead of paid a script hash
you could put the whole script in an
output like a multi-city you could just
have all three of your keys in your
output script and that would save space
over all your output is 20 bytes and
then you reveal your whole hundred byte
script so you save those 20 bytes same
same amount but proportionally less time
but it's you know it is some space
savings overall but it's better to keep
the output spot size small for you is if
you do this does it actually work so it
might not properly
yeah so so it don't I wouldn't recommend
this it probably will not really work
maybe eventually it'll get confirmed if
you find people to confirm it for you
but most nodes will ignore these kinds
of things okay so the question for today
what if we want really really big
scripts so two and three multi-sig is
cool we can just show all three keys and
there's 33 bytes of data that don't
really get used right if you're signing
with two of the three keys well that
means one of the keys never got used it
was sort of there and pointless for
whatever it's 33 bytes so what if you
want to do like 2 of 50 multi-sig so
here's 50 different keys any two of
these people can sign maybe you're in a
company there's 50 employees and the
policy is that okay any of these two
people can use the coins for this like
you know spending to buy lunch or
whatever so how would you do to a 50
moles sake
any ideas okay you commit and only
reveal part of a commitment so the cause
of in solution to all of luck change
problems Merkel trees right that's sort
of the solution for all throw a Merkel
tree on it which is sort of actually
what I'm working on now for another
things so yeah you commit to some kind
of route and then you reveal only part
of what you've committed to so the idea
which is from some there's debate about
who came up with this stuff right masked
like Peter wool was into it but then
someone else said they wrote a paper
about it I don't know it was like 2013
2014 the idea the original idea was make
a Merck alized
abstract abstract syntax tree so if you
have done any like programming language
courses
you probably recognize the term Maps the
abstract syntax tree asked which is sort
of how compilers work they make this
tree so the idea is okay we'll make
every node in that tree like a merkel
root so every single opcode can be
revealed and be like swapped out and
it's like super crazy that's
sort of overkill so that was part of the
initial idea and paper but a much
simpler way the reason about it and
program it would just be okay something
like pay to script Merkel Ruth where I
in my output script I have a route and
then I reveal that there is a script
that goes into that route and then I
execute that script so for example I
make four different scripts so this
would be say - wait no anyway it's just
for staff a different scripts there's no
to choose and that results in four right
but you know this is Allison Bob this is
Bob Carol this is Carolyn Dave this is
David or something and any of these any
of these two people but you know four
different groups can sign and then this
is what you actually put in your output
script and then when you want to spend
you say okay I'm going to provide a
proof so to spend reveal which I'm
spending so for example I'm spending
using script three and then I reveal a
path to the route which would be I
reveal four and this and then you
compute you say okay hash to these two
things together get that hash these two
things together you get that and confirm
that the result is equal to what was in
the output script and if it is okay
you've provided a valid proof a valid
inclusion proof that script three was
inside this root what's kind of cool in
this case you do not need the binary
tree to be perfect you can have
different heights because you're not
committing to the height of the tree
when you're sending to it so you could
have the you know the default case could
be here and then a really big tree that
goes down a lot over here so these in
most cases yeah well most cases it's
gonna be Alice and Bob signing and then
Carol and Dave and Edna and whatever are
unlikely so I'm gonna put it I'm gonna
put Allison Bob here
and then have the tree sort of
asymmetrically getting longer over here
so that when Alice and Bob sign they can
just reveal this and then when the other
people sign they're gonna have to reveal
this and this and then i optimize my
myspace for the most likely case so
that's kind of cool what else so yeah
however there are a probable game
there's a bunch of problems one okay two
of fifty is cool but what about so in
the case of two of fifty let's just look
through it you know fifty choose two I
couldn't make the little numbers and
parentheses the right way so that's a
thousand two hundred twenty five
different scripts and that would result
in it if you do a regular whatever
regular binary tree balanced I don't I
forget all the words you get a tree
height of 11 which is like actually kind
of it's like ah so close right if it was
1024 of you ten but a little over and
actually since it doesn't have to be
symmetric you can get like three high
ten for most leaves and then eleven for
some of them anyway so your proof size
is gonna be 352 bytes which is you know
okay and if you didn't use math you can
say well I'm just gonna have a pay to
script hash and the script is just gonna
show all 50 keys and have you know opt
to all 50 keys op three and that would
be about well plus three or something
but 1650 bytes so masked is an
improvement and it's sort of like hey
I'm doing log n write for all the
different scripts I have log in if I
actually committed to all the thousand
two hundred twenty-five scripts with
each of the two keys it'd be much bigger
but I don't actually have to because
I've got this whole 50 choose two in
here so I've got two things right I've
got this combinatorial thing and then
this log thing and in balance it's like
okay man like better but not actually
that awesome right you're going from
thousand 1.6 K to 350 bytes it gets
worse let's say I want to do 25 of 50
well that's 50 choose 25 which is around
100 trillion different combinations the
the tree height would not be 47 the
proof size is gonna be wait did
do that wrong hold on I think I'm I was
47 by 32 is one 504 okay sorry I just
put 20 I love for some reason I had 22
there sorry I'll fix that but that is
correct yeah one 504 so 1.5 K whereas
the raw would still be 1,650 these are
about the same this is not a great space
savings right your your proofs are huge
in fact I would say it's not only not
much better it's worse right you're
gonna have to compute two hundred
trillion hashes in order to compute that
root as the person creating the output
script to verify inclusion you have to
compute 47 hashes which is fine but 200
rolling hashes is doable but that's
gonna take a while and that's annoying
and yeah how long hours days I don't
know doable but not fun so mass doesn't
really get you necessarily what you want
here although this is kind of a silly
case but none of the things really get
you what you want here because of these
sort of combinatorial problems okay any
questions about or or questions or
opposition's if I have screwed up some
mess part of it is when you so compare
these two if I show a tree height of 10
or 11 huh that's weird there's like
thousand different scripts around in
this tree if I show a tree height of
forty seven that's really weird someone
either was just joking around and made
this weird sparse tree with all these
branches to just screw around and have a
height of 47 or there's 200 trillion
possible spending you know outcomes so
it reveals information about the things
that were not spent even though it
doesn't reveal what the scripts were it
to some extent reveals how many there
were okay
so even okay but still it is kind of
useful right in the - of 50k
yes this is better you know you have to
compute a couple thousand something
hashes no big deal
you you reduce your size from one point
6 K to 3 and 52 bytes that's a good deal
here kind of not but this is also sort
of a crazy there's other ways to address
this but anyway it's pretty good there's
there's sort of two or more than two
different ways to implement this you
could just say okay we're gonna have pay
the script Merkel route where you have a
template where it's like op op two or op
of three or something and then some data
and the idea is when you spend it you
have to provide a proof and then the
script itself and then you execute the
script another way which is kind of cool
and people were talking about it
recently you have this called tail call
recursion looking thing where the idea
is if you evaluate your script and then
there's two items left on the stack at
the end what you say is okay the
whichever is bottom or top one of these
items the bottom one is a you know
merkel root and then the other odd item
on the stack is the proof and arguments
you know another script so you can sort
of recursively say okay well i went down
into this script with this proof and
then executed it and then things were
left on the stack and it was another
proof for another merkel root um so
that's kind of cool
you can make all sorts of crazy things
with that i don't know how useful
recursion recursion is in this case but
there could be cases you're already in a
binary tree so my personal thing is like
why not just keep it simple and pay to a
script merkel root but there's people
who they think like no this should be
more expressive like programming
language e wise anyway so that's their
state of mess mast has code there's a
pull request and bit right yeah so
there's some people who are really in
the mast and like Bitcoin let's make a
soft work and there's also people we're
not as enthusiastic and so it's like no
one's like opposed to it like this is a
bad idea this will break Bitcoin but
there's dead
varying levels of like let's let's get
this in you can do all these cool things
versus and like is this really a
priority is what are we gonna use with
it kind of thing okay any questions
about this I think we have yes
quick break and then I'll do good off
return which seems unconnected but I
will show you how this connects to these
issues we have
okay so I've returned it was in the
problem set you basically put this
opcode in the front of your script and
that Flags it as forever unspent able as
an output so you put shouldn't put much
money into these outputs because they
are basically destroyed opera turn means
you you know immediately returned from
the the script evaluation and you return
a false I think it used to be return
whatever is on the top of the stack
right which meant you could just spend
anyone's money by using opportunity so
they they they saw fork that to say no
opera turn always fails instead of opera
turn always tribute Lee succeeds which
means you just put them up or turn to
take anyways money so they figured that
one out pretty quick so people use off
return to put data into the blockchain
why do people do this so it doesn't you
know you can't spend it you can't do
anything with this data but why do
people do this
it's kind of cool right to prove it's
there right they just you want to put
some data in and you just want to say
hey I thought of this first I'm making a
patent or I whatever you put data people
people use a lot of opera turn people
what was it like 10 percent yeah so
that's
[Music]
so that's a lot of data people using it
um there's a better way okay so what if
you wanted to do a zero byte opera turn
it's not quite the same right because an
opera turn everyone can see it and in
some cases you might want that you might
want to put an offer turn so that it's
publicly visible but in a lot of cases
in most cases I don't care about
someone's random opera turn usually what
you're putting into opera terms are like
hashes right because you don't have much
space anyway you have like 40 bytes or
something so usually your space
constrained so you put the hash of some
document and then someone can prove no
look I put the document on the
blockchain by putting the hash of it
that's a commitment to that document
itself so I show that I had this data at
some time before this block came out
right that's essentially what you're
proving you're proving you knew it
before a certain time which is it in
many cases really useful I mean that's
sort of the whole point of the
blockchain to prove that you knew about
this transaction before a future
transaction tries to double spend it you
want to file a patent and hey had this
idea first or you know prove these
things okay how can we do this with zero
bytes overhead okay you put it in the
signature and this was not obvious and
like no one thought of this until a year
or two ago I think it was an upholsterer
but I could be wrong but I just
associate it with him because he worked
on it but I'm not a hundred percent sure
and he called it pay to contract hash
which is confusing it's not a it's not
at all the same as fada script hash it's
not at all the same as paid a puppy ash
but it's called paid a contract hash
which makes it really confusing Bitcoin
has really confusing names right like
scripts it or pub key script wait script
pub key script pub key does not have to
have a pub key in it in most cases it
doesn't it has a funky hash or a script
hash it doesn't have to have anything in
it but it's called screw
Punkie and then script sig usually has
signatures but again not always and
there's all sorts of confusing names
anyway here's our new contribution to
confusing names kay to contract hash
which is not really paying to anything
there doesn't have to be a contract
there is a hash involved but yeah okay
so it's a weird name as you can't
actually detect the contract you know
paying to it but okay to review a
snorrison I'm gonna use snore signatures
this still works in ECDSA but you see
the SA is weird annoying and it also
makes more sense than Schnoor signatures
so I'll explain that but but it totally
works in EC it is DSA today so the idea
of the short signature is okay this is
my private key this is the message I
want to sign this is a random sort of
temporary private key I come up with and
then this is that temporary private key
turned into a public key write x Gina
gets the public key version and then two
to evaluate two to verify the signature
you just multiply both sides by G so you
get s times G K turns into our little a
turns into big a this is just the hash
32-byte hash so it's it stays the same
so the signature is R and s the sorry
the R and s so the signature and the
pump key is a and the message is out
okay so that's the signing or close
enough to the signing that's using
Bitcoin so pay to pub paid to contract
hash says okay I want to put our betray
data into my signature in a way that I
can prove it was there so here's the
normal equation now what if I redefined
K normally K is just a random number but
now I'm gonna redefine k k is now J so J
is my new real random number and then
I'm going to add the Hat no there's no G
there shoot anyway G you should not be
there but it should be there sorry okay
they so I redefined K as J which is an
actual random number
plus the hash of the data I want to
commit to and J times G I think yeah
yeah anyway and then the signature it's
still the same equation right I'm just
saying okay it's this new K minus this
thing and so nobody necessarily knows
that I'm doing this right if I just tell
you okay you know if I just tell you R
and s the equation still holds
it's just that K is a little special
right i-44 anyone else it looks like a
random number right it's a random number
plus this other hash not times G so it's
a random number plus a hash which hashes
look pretty random so it's a random
number plus some other random number
no one's gonna sell that anything's
weird about this however it is unique in
that I've got this random number plus
the hash of that random number times G
in it and this extra data I put in okay
so to verify if I don't tell you about
this verification looks the same
what if I do tell you about it though so
normally this thing RS pump use a
message exam but the signer can prove
that r is not kg that there's this other
K and you know that well it's K but
there's something else in our I can
prove that r is special after the fact
right everyone knows what R is but I can
then prove that something was in are
also never reveal K even after the fact
that'll let you figure out the person's
private key so the idea is I can prove
that R equals j plus the hash of the
data and j times G here's where it's a
little confusing right because this is
this is already pub key and you're
multiplying by G again right so that's
where this is you know anyone can
compute this right because I can say hey
here's you already know our I can give
you a J and some data such that J plus
the hash of this data and J itself times
G equals R
I can't Forge this right if I try to
forge this I say after the fact I want
to come up with I just made our randomly
right I didn't have any actual data and
then after the fact I want to come up
and then lie and say ya know I put this
data in to this are okay now we need to
solve for J right because my proof is
gonna be J in this data so I've got the
data I want and I want to figure out
what J's so J is the hash of this data
and J times G minus R oh shoot right
that would be the equation I have to
solve if I want to falsely prove that
this data went into it the problem is
I've got this thing where it's like J is
defined in terms of the hash of J I
don't I don't that's that's gonna be
hard right if I'm defining J in terms of
the hash of J I'm stuck because that's
not how hash functions don't let me do
that so this is actually kind of cool
because it's a proof that there was some
extra data that went in to the random R
point before the signing happened right
or well it's yeah it had to be before
the signing happened because the
signature has are in it and s is a
function of r and this is cool because
if you don't know about it it just looks
like a regular signature with a like
regular R value but if I tell you about
it I was like yeah when I sign that I
actually put some extra data into here
so that's kind of better than off return
right there's zero bytes overhead you're
gonna sign anyway so you can put data
inside a signatures are point you can
even do it with other people's
signatures there's no real private
information here if I just can use some
data it's totally safe right hey here's
some data okay here's the J point that
goes in that you know constructs this
and they are like okay sounds good
I can put someone else's data into this
you just handle the data they give you
the proof which in that case is just J
so it's upper turn with zero byte
overhead this is really cool I believe
this is being used for like open
timestamps now as of a few I think right
but but it's also nice it's not like a
soft pork or anything this is just a fun
trick you can do with your signatures so
you can do this today if you want it and
then prove to people later like hey I
put my name into my signature direct
replacement for the operator you you
commit to the route right see so in
their case this data is the Merkel route
and then you can then prove so you can
you know put a Merkel route here and
then I prove that there's a Merkel route
inside my signature and then I also
prove a branch so that the data is in
the Merkel route which is then in the
our point which is in the signature
which is in the blocks Merkel tree which
is in the blockchain so you've got like
four or five different proofs going on
but they should all be working okay so
this is this is kind of cool any idea
why I was explaining all this in terms
of like mast and multi-sig like these
seem totally unconnected right any idea
so yeah it took Bitcoin people like well
over a year to see the after the you
know in retrospect really obvious
connection and thing to do with this
but it took a year or two and then
someone Greg posted on the mailing list
in January like hey wait you can use
this for something else and then it was
like oh shoot like how did no one think
of that
so it's called tap root and I don't know
why Greg called it that Greg Maxwell
he's got was a big beard who works on
Bitcoin he's super smart and stuff and
it uses this pay to contract hash
construction and it's the same equation
but it took us a year or two to figure
out that you can do this so the
motivation here is paid a pub key hash
and pay to script hash look different
right you can tell just looking at the
output these are totally different you
know output scripts one of them's got a
pub - one of them's got a script -
different
we don't want everything to look
different then you can sort of sort
things you can try to differentiate try
to track people's coins things like that
you want it to all look uniform to make
it more anonymous so one thing you could
do is just use pay to script - for
everything you can put a pump key you
know single essentially one of one
multi-sig or just just the beta script
hash pay to pub key hash script in paid
a script hash you wouldn't do that you
just have you'd have that you'd have the
direct pay to pub key put into a script
hash so that like it looks like a script
- and then the script is public key up
check sig it's actually not really any
overhead I think you actually save a
bite or two nobody does that
you could that might solve like 80% of
what this is trying to solve it's but
it's kind of boring it doesn't use cool
math so anyway okay the other the other
the other observation is that in most
cases scripts you have these sort of
scripts and there's a hidden option
which is or everyone signs so in the
case of like two of 50 multi say well if
all 50 people sign that's okay right
that's no worse so if it's 25 of 50
multi-sig if all 50 people happen to
sign sure that's you know it's no loss
of security so the idea is you use this
pay to script paid a contract hashed
instruction to merge Paytas pub key hash
and pay to script a sh so that a single
output can do both the ID as you make a
key J and J is an actual key like you
have the private key for it it's a
regular old pump key and you have a
script Z and instead of sending either
to the script Z in a pane of script hash
construction or to you know hash this
key J and said to the pub key ash you
say I'm gonna compute key C which is J
plus the hash of my script concatenated
with J times G so this is the same as
the thing I just did with the operator
mannan zero bytes right and then I send
money to it
and then what do I do I've sent money to
this C point can I sign with C's private
key right
I know I know little J right that's a
regular key can do I know little C sure
right yeah I know that little C is just
the J private key plus this hash so if I
want to treat it as a pay to pub key
hash I just signed with little C assign
my transaction and I'm good
nobody has to know that I did this
however if I want to make it into a beta
script a sh I reveal the script Z and
the you know sub ki J and then I put
some arguments on and then run the
script so if I don't want to show that
there was a script I don't have to write
it just just sign with this the private
keys that nobody knows that there was a
script at all and it may so maybe 80
maybe if everyone's using this 80% of
the time that's what happens maybe there
was a script in there maybe there wasn't
can't tell right however if I want to
reveal hey actually this time I'm using
the script so I revealed J&Z everyone
computes okay well if I add J to the
hash of Z and J times G does that equal
C the key that is in the output script
itself and if it does cool that was a
valid proof that you actually committed
to Z and now I run the script to see any
questions about this makes sense so it's
actually pretty simple it follows
directly from the proofs from the paid
contract hash and it's really cool
because Opie I thought it was doing
anyway so what you can do is you can
make the sum of everyone's keys and so
in store signatures we can do this
and we can sign without revealing each
other's private keys so you can say okay
in what I'm gonna do is J is the sum of
like 50 different pub keys and then Z is
that Merkel tree of two of 50 signatures
so if I want to use two of 50 I have to
reveal and then I have to do the proof
but if I can get all 50 of 50 people to
sign they can produce a signature with
private key little C so when everyone's
cooperating it it you don't even see
that there was a script involved and you
can do this with signatures you cannot
do this with ECDSA so probably this
would be you know put into Bitcoin
alongside ashen or signature kind of
construction and this seems useful
because in most cases most smart
contracts most multi say does have sort
of an all participants sign clause
even if we don't code it in right now
it's generally the case like you know
two of three will be saying well three
of three is good and if you do three of
three
hey you don't even see that there was
two of three and so that preserves
privacy it's safe space and most of the
time all the participants can be online
so that's the same that's the same basic
ideas and lightning if everyone's
cooperative you don't even see that
there was a lightning Channel right you
just you know together broadcast a
transaction with just two of two
multi-state but in lightning you do see
that there was two of two multi sakes so
you can sort of see oh it was either a
channel or multi-sig but in this kind of
construction
you wouldn't even show that you say okay
this is actually two of two multi-sig
but we can merge them Oh
other weird trick you can make a public
key and prove that there is no known
private key right so what if I only want
this script Z and there is no set of
everyone signing right I don't want that
to be a requirement what if I only want
this script hash I can do that so
interactively I can use someone else's J
if I if there's
you know if I'm sending into a script
that involves someone else they say hey
can you come up with a key J I'm going
to compute a key see that's J plus the
hash of the script comma J times G and
then I can prove that to you after the
fact and you can say okay well I know
it's my key so interactive I can show
that it's someone else's key
non-interactive I can just say look I
know the preimage of the x-coordinate of
J so basically I know I can prove to you
that like there's no way I came up with
this point on the curve in the normal
like multiplied by G way right because
if I know you know that sort of shows
that I came up with the x-coordinate by
just hashing a random number or non
random number if it's the hash of zero
or if the hash of you know some some
anything the idea is I randomly picked
an x-coordinate on this curve figured
out what the y-coordinate was turn that
into a point and then used it in this
construction if I do that you can be
pretty sure that I don't know the
private key for J because I didn't
compute it the right way does that make
sense yeah so you can do that that's a
way to then prove to other people like
there is no J right it's a point on the
curve but it's a random point on the
curve so there's no way I can sign with
C right the only way that this is gonna
that this you know I sent a pub key C
and I prove to you look C is not a key
that anyone can sign with however there
is a point J and there's a script Z and
you can execute the script so that's
that's useful in many cases where you
want to prove to people that look there
is no key here it's just a script and
then you you know everyone will find out
later when you spend it but they don't
have to know that there was no key they
just know that the script got executed
so that that's a nice sort of hatch
where you can you know default if
there's any use cases where in the
current script hash you want that exact
same functionality and you don't want
this new functionality you can sort of
get rid of it this way
okay the idea however is that we were
trying to make your special transaction
scripts not stand out but it's more that
you can say let's say I have my wallet
software and it always uses p2w sa fee -
SH or something then I can say oh I bet
this is the same person I can try to
track who's spending yeah probably a big
part of it is privacy maybe they're you
know discriminate against that Emma's
like minors probably the minors don't
care but it's more like if if everyone's
using software that could create similar
transactions then it becomes much harder
to tell people apart and it has more
privacy for the transactions they need
to know they need to know the script and
J which is not obvious from see right if
you jetan c is the only thing you see on
the blockchain in the output and so they
just say it's a key
probably someone knows the private key
maybe there's some weird thing like this
going on you don't have to use this
right and then yeah so they won't know
what J or Z are yeah yeah you can
publish it you can publically publish it
if you want and tell everyone in the
world hey this C is actually this J Plus
this script Z they still can't spend it
right that's all that can be public even
beforehand and then they can see oh
there's a script and a key and you can
also say sign something and prove that
you know the private key for J so you
can say I'm not you know I can prove
that I'm not doing this
there is no J kind of thing so you can
prove all those things but you don't
need to write if you for normal usage
you just send a key C spend from key C
you're done and if you want to
to spend from the script to Z you just
provide J the script Z and then execute
the script so it's nice and that even
you might have had a script and then you
didn't use it so you didn't reveal that
there was a script so it helps with
privacy it helps with efficiency in many
cases because if you don't need to use
the script you don't have to so in a lot
of cases you say all you know everyone's
all three of the two of three multi
SIG's are on board so let's you see
instead of the script Z so it's pretty
cool okay so questions about this go
into the next crazy thing okay so yeah a
little notes about taproot anyone can
make a key and script and send to it
only the pub keys are needed right so if
I want to send to something that's you
know three of three Alice Bob and Carol
add it all together or two of the three
of Alice and Bob and Carol I don't have
to even ask Alice Bob and Carol if I
know their public keys I can just
compute all this myself and send the
send money to their send that one right
and I can compute any construction I
want I can make it one of three right I
know that there's Alice BA I know Alice
Bob and Carols public keys and I can say
hey Alice Bob and Carol I'm giving you
all money and you can fight over it or
you can cooperate like it's you know any
of you get it and so the idea is one of
three multi-sig script goes into here
and then three of three is here so if
you cooperate you save a little bit of
space on them and the fees are smaller
but if you don't cooperate any of you
can grab it immediately I don't know how
useful that is but you could do this
right you you don't need knowledge of
any private keys to construct see only
the pub keys are needed that's actually
really nice because you're creating so
that's that's the same is currently the
case in Bitcoin right if you're creating
an output script like paid a pub key
hash paid a script hash there's no
private keys involved in that process
right you just tell everyone okay which
differs and is the important distinction
between the next school thing
which is craft route also Greg Maxwell
like a week or two after taproot they're
not actually that similar but it was
like wait you know people are sort of
talking about it so the idea is allow a
lot of scripts with a proof that goes up
in size with of one okay it doesn't go
up in size so the Merkel proofs right
mast grow in log n so if you've got a
million different scripts you're gonna
take twenty something like twenty hashes
or whatever to prove that what's a proof
that go grows in of one of the number of
things being proven it's actually not
it's kind of obvious like I want to
prove I want to prove something
and the proof size does not change
regardless of how many things
I'm proving well it's just a signature
right if I make a million signatures
they're all the same size so I could
instead of making a Merkel root I just
have all these little leaves and I just
sign them all and a leaf with a
signature it's just as good okay so the
idea is this is called graft root it's
similar to trap fruit in that it's got
sort of two execution paths you send to
a key see and there's two ways to spend
from it so you can use the regular pay
to pub key hash mode where you're just
spending from C you just sign with key C
your transaction same as in tap root
same as in regular Bitcoin right now
that's the easy one the script version
is I show a script s and a signature
from key C on the message s and then I
execute that script so this is kind of
cool right you say look I'm sending you
a key and either that key itself signs
or that key endorses a script to the to
be executed and I can make as many of
these as I want right so if I want a
thousand different scripts it's not like
I have to prove
inclusion in three that's gonna be
height 22 or height 12 or whatever I
just have a signature saying okay kisi
signed this to of fifty multi-sig kisi
also signed this three of 52 of two
other two of fifty multi Singh so the
one that I'm actually using I just
provide the proof that it's you know the
proof of inclusion is just a signature
questions about this makes sense kind of
weird it works
the problem is did I even well that's
the real problem is there is this kisi
right so there's this sort of root key
that controls the whole thing right
implicit like the idea is kisi can all
you know endorses all the different
leaves so then in the case of mast
you've got let's say four different
scripts that can execute all four of
those are committed to by the Merkle
root in the case of graft root let's say
you have four different scripts see
signs all four of those different
scripts the thing is seek ensign 10
scripts sees got total control over this
output whereas before in the Merc the
mast idea it can be different people
right it could be Alison Bob Carol and
Dave Edna and Gertrude I don't know and
they might not be friends none no single
entity there has full control so the
idea of of this is well you can combine
a whole bunch of people the key C is
essentially everyone and they all have
to sign off on all the different scripts
that could happen and then distribute
those signatures on those scripts which
are groups so okay any basic idea makes
sense this one's a little weirder I
think I don't know if there's also a way
in this so in this one there's a way to
prove that there is no key C so let's
sort of say look it's only gonna be this
script and no one's gonna sign in the
normal just the key signs
that there's also a way to do that here
it's much less useful though because
what you essentially do is you you start
with your script and then you compute a
signature on it
but you also prove that there was no
private key that made the signature you
have time it's actually really fun what
you do is so normally you say like okay
s equals K minus the hash of my message
and R times 0.8 what if I want to prove
to you that there is no a G equals R
minus the hash of message oh hey I want
to prove that like I do not know that
private key and nobody knows it so what
I do is I actually have to do it both I
say okay I know the preimage of the
x-coordinate same with our wait can I do
this
anyway well basically what I do is I
compute a public key randomly or no I I
first get the message I want to sign I
make a random R yeah yeah I make a
random R and I show that it's random
right I know the preimage of its
coordinates or something I can prove
that I didn't construct this I don't
know the private key and then I solve
for a and s essentially so I can show
look I've got a signature but I can
prove that no one signed right because I
came up with the I think I'd make a
random ass and then I solve for a I
solve for big a you know make a random s
multiply it by G solve for it right so a
divided by hash of our weight I can't do
that can i yeah I can this is good
equals
I know it's equals R - s G alright so I
come up with a random R put it in here
come up with a message I want to sign
and then solve for a so I can do that
and I can prove that there was you know
I can prove that there was no real a
because of the way I constructed it like
I know weird things about RNA and so I
can show that this is not a real
signature however in this case it's not
that useful in the case of taproot it's
useful because I might want to prove to
people look this is just a script there
is no key in this case I can still do
that I can say there's just a script
there is no key but then I can only do
it once right I can only have one thing
the whole idea of graft root is I can
have a million different scripts that
are all going into one key okay so the
problem is the root key must die in
every script and now you need to use
private keys to create an address that's
not great right it's maybe okay but you
haven't had to do that before so so now
we have to sign off on every script that
we're endorsing in order to compute an
address you can do this after the fact
though so that's kind of the interesting
thing about this is you can say okay I'm
sending the key C which is this root key
that's all 50 participants and then
after the fact after it's been confirmed
in the blockchain those 50 participants
can say actually you know what
two of two of 50 is good we're not
suspending the money right now but we're
all agreeing that yeah any two of us can
spend this money later and so they all
get together and all 50 sign with the
root key see all the different scripts
those 1225 scripts and then hand those
signatures out to the respective people
who who would be interested in that
signature right so Alice and Bob if you
want to spend the money we all made a
signature endorsing your - of - you know
- of 50 your two keys and Bob and Carol
if you two want to spend the money we've
made a script
that's a you know that's endorsed by us
saying your two keys can spend it it's
really cool the overhead is one
signature so you can have that like
hundred trillion different you know 2050
choose 25 which is 100 trillion well you
got a sign 100 trillion times but when
you spend from it it's small it's an
extra thirty three bytes of overhead
yeah the overhead is just a signature
right so you say okay here's key see
here's a signature from it here's the
script to endorse the script being
executed it's not actually 64 bytes you
can get the overhead in 233 bytes
because you can aggregate the s values
of the signature I'll talk about this on
Wednesday I don't think I actually came
up with this but Greg cites me on it and
it's like a yes no one thought of this
huh but there's like a non-interactive
partial aggregation of these things
which I was really hoping we'd get into
Bitcoin itself but I think it's too slow
but in this case it's not that slow so
people like yeah we'll use it here okay
so this is kind of cool because it's
simple right it's just more scripts can
be at at any time it's all one scaling
so if you have a million different
scripts proving one of them just takes
32 bytes or 33 or something C can be a
threshold signature of many different
parties the signature can be aggregated
within the transaction
the downside is this interactive setup
where you can't just take Alice and Bob
and Carols key and send to a graph route
to a three multi-sig right Alice and Bob
and Carol need to sign something in some
cases that's no big deal
right in some cases your connect to them
over the internet and all the
participants are cooperating sure will
sign will create addresses or will pre
sign all sorts of different addresses
beforehand doable but sometimes you
don't want this interactive set up
sometimes I want to be able to send to
participants of my choosing without
their cooperation usually for standing
people money they're ok with it right
but sometimes you don't want them to be
online okay
so put this all together the idea and
the
the goal for this and I think the way
it's gonna work in Bitcoin but this is
still you know research kind of you have
a unified output script so let's say
it's a templated with op v and you say
okay op v pub key now when i want to
spend to it i have a bunch of options to
spend I can just put a signature on the
stack and then the program says oh
there's a signature let me check if the
signature matches the public key
you know this funky and if it does cool
the move money moves
that's pub pay to pub key hash mode
except it's not a match
another thing I can do is provide a
point J a script and a series of
arguments for the script and that's
Tapper I verify that J plus the you know
I verify that J plus the hash of J and
the script times G is equal to that pump
key and then I execute that script
another way to do it is if I've got this
I've got C which is also just a point
and I signature on the script and then a
script and a bunch of arguments then I
say oh this is crafter I'll verify this
script this signature on this script and
then execute with these arguments so I
was it would be cool if you could do it
just based on the number of items pushed
but you might want to put like a flag or
something here to distinguish between
these two if it's this if there's just
one element you can just quickly say
okay it's made of funky but to
distinguish between these two there
might be weird edge cases where it's
like well one of the arguments could
also look like a script and annoying
thing so you might put some like flag
bite but anyway it's kind of nice in
that when you send to an output you send
to an address all the addresses look the
same they just look like public keys but
they could be any of these things and
you only find out after the fact
in not only that you could have the same
key have a taproot and also have a
grafter right you could you could have
you know so they're clear
in a dress and I've gotten my wallet
well there's three different ways I can
spend this I can spend this with
everyone all 50 people signing or I can
spend it with the like you know a single
script that's been endorsed this way
that's got like priority and then I can
also spend it with one of the millions
of scripts that have been endorsed this
way so I can use all three this is a
little bit more efficient right because
you're just revealing the script and a
point this one you have to reveal
oh no wait sorry this is wrong there's
no see you already know see it's it's
still a little more efficient yeah
there's no see there you already know
see you just put the signature on the
script yeah okay so this is graph root
tap root and then also part of the
script can be masked you can have a mask
top code you can combine all these
things in crazy ways and have like
really powerful scripting that way okay
so when this stuff was proposed the
argument was hey I don't want to spend
to a public key I want to spend to a
public key hash because quantum
computers are coming and when the
quantum computers come if you know my
pub key you can just calculate my
private key and take all my money but if
you only know my public key hash quantum
computer doesn't help you there right
you're not going to be able to compute
the preimage of a hash with the quantum
computer there's yeah that's true all of
those statements are true except in
practice it's it's dumb because if
there's a quantum computer that can
compute your private key from your
public key
the only time using Punky hashes will
help you is if somehow that quantum
computer takes a really long time to
compute your private key right because
if it only takes them a minute to
compute it well you have to reveal your
public key to spend your money and then
the attacker who has this nifty quantum
computer can just say oh that's his
public key I just saw it right
and he signed and using his bubble key I
just computers private key sign a
different message and broadcast it and
maybe I attach a higher fee because I
don't care it's not my money and the
miners are like well there's two
different transactions one sending over
here one sending over here this one has
a much higher fee I'll use this one and
the attacker with the quantum computer
still takes all your money they can't
take it at rest they have to wait for
you to try to spend it and take it but
you could say okay well actually I'm
moving up five paid Punky hash and then
for this I have to reveal pumpking
signature for this I reveal pub key J
component of pump key script for this I
revealed you know see you missing but
it's like kind of ugly waste of space
and in most cases doesn't provide a lot
of protection
so there's hopefully better ways to deal
with this one thing that I have sort of
been joking about but it would be kind
of fun to put it into wallets you can
actually use tap root to commit to a
Lamport like hash based pub key so in
tap root this is actually quantum secure
I hesitate to advertise this but it is a
commitment that is not that the quantum
computer cannot Forge right the the the
whole wait where does it where as I
saying the J equals hash of yeah this
thing is still a problem for a quantum
computer right you got I want to compute
a J such that J equals this hash times G
minus R the Jim J is in there as well
even with a quantum computer maybe I can
compute an arbitrary J and find its
discrete log you know find the private
key but it's still not going to satisfy
this equation so I can't find I can't
after the fact find a script in a J to
compute
see so that is safe even if a quantum
computer exists right because that's
based on the security the hash function
so that's kind of an interesting little
tidbit like hey this is this taproot
construction this is hash based quantum
computer appears and we say look we no
longer allow C we no longer allow the
normal spend where you sign with key C
because signature is all this elliptic
curve stuff it's broken however we do
allow you to prove that there was a
script Z can you know can committed to
in C and then maybe this script has like
a quantum safe signature in it and then
we can use that what's nice about that
is you can start using it sooner and
without the overhead of all the extra
space taken by the quantum signature
because it's sort of a back-up plan it's
like well normally I'm just signing with
C right because I know what you know
this is just my regular key and I do
this but worst case scenario if a
quantum computer appears in ten years
I've got my other backup key here so
that's kind of a cool thing I don't know
how useful it is in practice but okay so
yeah you got all these three things the
other thing about this is I don't know
big multi-sig is one use case it seems
really powerful and like hey I can make
these you know millions of different
scripts and like Merkle trees of
different scripts and tappero and
graphic not a ton of like really good
real-world use cases though I think that
would motivate it a lot more because a
lot of it a lot of the hesitation from
people working on Bitcoin it's like okay
what this is really cool but like what
are we gonna do with it
and multi-sig is not as I'll talk about
and Wednesday multi-sig itself is not
the best motivation because once we have
more signatures and aggregate signatures
there's direct ways to do multi-sig that
are actually more privacy-preserving
more space preserving so we need use
cases and that was that's one of the
debates like okay what do we do with
this this is kind of cool you can make
all sorts of weird smart contracts but
what are some
world news cases there's also sort of
argument okay mast versus graph route
versus both well if you have graphed
route do you really need mast anymore
right instead of this big Merkel tree
you just have the signatures endorsing
the leaves so it sort of seems better
scalability there but grassroots
interactive so maybe you still want
masked maybe have both there's all sorts
of debate on this and so that in
practice they that may mean that sense
people are arguing next year the year
after it's hard to get everyone on board
to do stuff there is code though some
things have code some of them are like a
lot of it's sort of obvious enough
they're like yeah craft room makes sense
just have them sign the taproot
construction there's code for but it's
not all like put together there's no
like spec for all these things so if
people are interested in this stuff
start coding it start trying it out come
up with cool use cases and maybe push
for one thing or another to get in
there's there's a pull request open in
Bitcoin right now foremast I don't know
some people are really into it and other
people are like I don't know also how to
implement math exactly so this is you
know still research kind of level but I
it seems that they're usable and that
may improve some our contract
functionality so cool stuff here any
questions about this alright cool
okay well so I'll do office hours
tomorrow at four we talk about projects
and stuff and the next class on
Wednesday will be even more crazy
elliptic curve stuff about aggregate
signatures for signatures multi
signatures threshold signatures things
like that weight and also privacy I
don't know how much of I'm gonna focus
on the signature part I also put like
privacy and coin joint in there which is
related but might be squished towards
the end if I don't have a ton of time